selon une étude américaine écoutez du
heavy métal permet d'éviter la
dépression selon ifr américaine la
pratique de la peine dangers de la
corruption aux nitrates favorise
provoque guéri le cancer le paludisme le
panaris des titres spectaculaire de ce
genre on entend presque chaque semaine
et vous vous demandez peut-être à force
qu'il faut penser de ces fameuses études
américaines qui ne sont pas toujours
américaine d'ailleurs et bien
aujourd'hui on va voir comment porter un
regard critique sur ce genre d' annonce
notamment en allant carrément lire soi
même ses études et ça va être une bonne
occasion de parler du fonctionnement de
la recherche scientifique
[Musique]
tout d'abord quand on entend parler
d'une étude de ce genre il ne s'agit pas
d' élucubrations avancée par n'importe
qui mais en principe d'un travail de
recherche mené par des chercheurs qui
appartiennent généralement un
laboratoire d'une université ou d'un
organisme de recherche en france ça peut
être le cnrs ou l'inserm ou leur
équivalent dans les autres pays
ses équipes de recherche travaillent sur
des sujets donnés pendant plusieurs mois
voire quelques années mais quand elles
font une découverte ou arrive à une
conclusion
eh bien elle n'en voit pas directement
un communiqué au journal de tf1 ou à la
rédaction du nouvel obs l'enor ya tout
un processus à respecter tout d'abord
l'équipe doit écrire un article pour
expliquer sa découverte
comment elle a été obtenue les
conclusions etc ces articles font
typiquement cinq à dix pages et c'est ce
que dans le langage de la recherche
qu'on appelle un papier cet article il
n'est même pas directement destinés à
des magazines scientifiques comme sur
ces vies ou encore la recherche mais il
est envoyé à une revue scientifique
spécialisée écrite par des chercheurs
pour des chercheurs des revues de ce
genre il en existe des milliers un
classé par discipline et qui bien sûr
sont presque toujours en anglais
puisqu'elle s'adresse à un public
international
quand l'éditeur d'une revue scientifique
reçoit un article d'une équipe de
recherche
il doit soit accepté de le publier soit
le refuser alors pour prendre sa
décision il ne fait pas selon son humeur
mais selon un processus appelé la re
lecture par les pairs
les pères ce sont d'autres chercheurs du
domaine indépendant de l'équipe initiale
que l'éditeur va contacter pour avoir
leur avis sur la qualité du travail
décrit dans le papier c'est relecteur
généralement ils sont deux ou trois vont
lire l'article et vont vérifier que les
principes de la méthode scientifique
soit respectée ils vont regarder le
protocole résultat les conclusions et
ensuite faire une recommandation à
l'éditeur sur la base de ces avis
l'éditeur décidera finalement d'accepter
ou pas la publication de l'article dans
sa revue et c'est seulement quand
l'article aura été publié dans une revue
spécialisée que dans les jours qui
suivent la presse grand public pourra
éventuellement en parler évidemment ça
restera un chaque jour des milliers
d'articles scientifiques sont publiés
sans que le journal de tf1 ou le figaro
en parle
la médiatisation ça n'arrive que pour
des résultats qui paraissent
particulièrement spectaculaires ou
intéressant tout ça vous vous expliquez
que quand vous voyez un titre du genre
selon une étude américaine le heavy
metal
permet de soigner la dépression eh bien
ça ne vient pas de nulle part mais a
priori un ça a été fait par des
chercheurs de vérifier par d'autres
chercheurs et 3 publiée dans une revue
scientifique spécialisée
alors attention à ce processus de
relecture par les pairs n'implique pas
qu'il faille y croire sur parole les
conclusions de n'importe quel article
scientifique mais au moins que ça semble
conforme aux règles de base de la
méthode scientifique
le problème c'est souvent qu'entre ce
que dit l'article
est-ce qu'on retrouve dans les médias il
ya parfois des distorsions des
exagérations voire carrément des
contresens
alors on va apprendre à regarder sa part
nous mêmes l'idéal pour se faire son
idée c'est de retrouver le papier
scientifique d'origine qui décrit
l'étude les artic grand public on trouve
dans les médias mentionnent souvent la
revue scientifique d'origine et les
auteurs et même dans le meilleur des cas
met un lien directement vers le papier
scientifique on peut souvent retrouvé
les textes originaux via des sites comme
google scholar arxiv ou sur les pages
web des labos de recherche
et sinon il paraît que certains
utilisent ces immeubles pour retrouver
gratuitement les textes de ses articles
quand vous avez le pdf d'un article
scientifique
la première page ressemblent toujours
plus ou moins à ça et on y voit déjà
plein de choses intéressantes
ici vous avez le titre qui est parfois
assez obscur et dans tous les cas
beaucoup moins spectaculaire est
affirmatif que ce qu'on peut retrouver
dans la presse ensuite un truc très
intéressant à observer c'est le journal
lui-même dans lequel le pâtis a été
publié car non tous les journaux
scientifiques ne se valent pas certains
journaux sont plus prestigieux d'autres
et donc beaucoup plus sélectif et
rigoureux sur les articles qu'ils
publient
d'autres journaux au contraire accepte
un peu n'importe quoi sans être très
regardant sur la qualité et il y en a
même qui se font payer pour accepté de
publier n'importe quel article bref
existent pour connaître le niveau de
prestige et d'exigence d'un journal
scientifique
il existe une mesure appelée impact
factor le facteur d'impact
c'est un chiffre qui est public et qui
évolue chaque année pour chaque journal
plus il est élevé plus le journal est
réputé recherché et exigeant les
journaux les plus prestigieux comme
saillens ou nature ont des facteurs
d'impact de l'ordre de 30 à 50
mais par exemple le malaise diane
journal of microbiology à un facteur
d'impact de 0,02 et ne vous fiez pas un
nom anglais qui claque un pour savoir si
un journal est sérieux par exemple entre
le journal comme sercel et ligne
international journal of cancer research
est bien le premier un facteur d'impact
de
12-7 vraiment pas mal et le second 0,14
alors qu'est-ce que ça prouve ces
facteurs d'impact est bien en dessous de
10 ont un il faut faire un peu attention
parce que ça signifie que ça n'est
certainement pas un journal très
exigeant et le processus de relecture
par les pairs n'aura probablement pas
été super super rigoureux bien sûr en
théorie dans un monde idéal on ne
devrait juger la qualité d'une
publication scientifique que sur ce
qu'elle contient mais en pratique
regarder le journal de publication donne
quand même une bonne idée de la rigueur
du processus d'examen qui a déjà été
appliquée donc un journal prestigieux ça
va plutôt dans le sens de rassurer
surtout si le résultat semble majeur est
important même remarque dans une moindre
mesure 1 quand même concernant les
auteurs c'est rassurant s'ils viennent
d'une université ayant pignon sur rue
s'ils ont déjà beaucoup publié dans le
domaine c'est le genre de choses qu'on
peut vérifier sur le site google scholar
ça ne prouve évidemment ryan définitif
mais comme toujours ça va dans le bon
sens attends qu on dit au sujet des
auteurs la plupart des journaux leur
impose de déclarer leurs éventuels
conflits d'intérêts donc s'il y en a en
théorie on les trouve mentionné bien
tout ça c'était les préliminaires
passons maintenant au plat principal le
contenu de l'article
[Musique]
la quasi totalité des articles
scientifiques sont écrits selon un
canevas convenu d'avancé
on y retrouve toujours cinq parties
d'abord un résumé appelé abstract puis
une introduction
ensuite la description des méthodes de
recherche et l'analyse la présentation
des résultats proprement dit est une
discussion et interprétations de ces
résultats
l'abstract c'est un bon point de départ
c'est souvent très très résumé mais ça
permet de savoir si l'article qu'on est
en train de lire traite à peu près du
sujet qu'on avait imaginé en lisant le
titre et ça permet de voir rapidement
les résultats et les conclusions
ensuite l'introduction qui peut être
assez longue permet aux auteurs
d'expliquer pourquoi ils ont voulu faire
cette recherche
et surtout comment elle s'inscrit dans
le cadre plus général des connaissances
scientifiques existantes et d autres
recherches précédentes sur le sujet ou
sur des sujets reliés par d'autres
équipes de recherche
cette section un peu bibliographiques
est importante parce qu'elle permet de
savoir d'où on part
prenons un exemple fictif si vous êtes
en train de lire un article qui prétend
que la musique métal a un impact sur la
dépression est bien la plausibilité
initial ne sera pas la même suivant ce
qui existe préalablement comme résultat
similaire
si l'introduction mentionne déjà plein
d'études montrant que la musique a des
effets thérapeutiques sur telle ou telle
maladie mentale ou bien que sur des rats
on a déjà obtenu des résultats du même
genre et bien vous allez plutôt partir
en vous disant que c'est crédible
au contraire si les études précédentes
mentionnés dans l'introduction ont déjà
spécifiquement regarder les effets du
rock du hip hop et de la house music sur
la dépression sans rien trouver
et bien pour montrer que ça marche
spécifiquement avec le heavy metal
il va falloir être super convaincant
pour le dire autrement une affirmation
extraordinaire demande des preuves
extraordinaires et quand on doit se
faire une idée sur un résultat de
recherche son positionnement par rapport
aux études antérieures joue évidemment
un rôle essentiel comme pour la qualité
de la revue scientifique cet argument ne
vous dit rien sur le travail lui-même
qui va être présenté mais il permet de
juger a priori de la plausibilité du
résultat et si dès le départ les
résultats sont peu plausible ça veut pas
dire qu'ils sont fous mais il va falloir
être d'autant plus prudents et exigeant
passons maintenant à la section suivante
intitulé généralement matériel méthodes
dans cette section et chercheur présente
comment ils s'y sont pris les
expériences ou analyse qu'ils ont fait
le protocole et cetera
mais sans tout de suite donnée les
résultats il présente juste les méthodes
mais il ya déjà plein de choses à
regarder un premier point évident c'est
sûr qu'ils at-on fait l'expérience ou
l'analyse quand on vous dit que la
musique métal un impact sur la
dépression est ce qu'on parle des
humains ou est-ce qu'il s'agit
d'expériences préliminaire faite sur des
souris c'est en effet très fréquent de
conduire des recherches sur des animaux
le plus souvent des rats ou des souris
parce que c'est plus simple plus rapide
mieux contrôler et c'est évidemment
quand on découvre un effet sur des rats
c'est un signe intéressant mais il ya
encore beaucoup de chemin avant de
pouvoir affirmer le même effet chez
l'être humain
je suis sûr que vous avez déjà vu dans
la presse des titres vous affirmant la
découverte d'un traitement
révolutionnaire pour telle ou telle
maladie
pour découvrir ensuite qu'en fait c'est
un résultat obtenu uniquement pour
l'instant sur des souris voire juste des
cellules de souris
deuxième élément important dans les
méthodes quand on étudie l'impact de
quelque chose il faut toujours ce qu'on
appelle un groupe de contrôle
il suffit pas de dire par exemple on
prend un groupe de gens souffrent de
dépression
on va leur faire écouter du métal une
heure par jour pendant trois semaines
pour voir si ensuite il vaut mieux mais
non parce que si effectivement il vaut
mieux en moyenne c'est peut-être pour
une raison qui n'a rien à voir avec les
coupes du métal le printemps arrive est
la météo avait changé que sais-je
pour espérer prouver quelque chose de
rigoureux il faut un groupe de contrôle
c'est-à-dire un second groupe aussi
similaire que possible au 1er mai à qui
on ne ferait pas écouté de métal pour
avoir un point de comparaison
et ce qui comptera ce sera la différence
entre le groupe étudié et le groupe de
contrôle
normalement procéder comme ça avec un
groupe de contrôle c'est la norme dans
les publications scientifiques
mais parfois il ya des pièges alors
c'est important de bien s'assurer de sa
d'ailleurs dans l'exemple fictif que je
décris on peut se demander ce que serait
un bon groupe de contrôle pas forcément
un groupe à qui on ne ferait rien écouté
un mais peut-être plus tôt un groupe à
qui ont fait écouter de la musique mais
pas du métal pour isoler spécifiquement
cet effet moi je vous laisse réfléchir à
la question
dans la section méthode c'est là que
vous allez aussi trouvé la description
ce qui a été fait et de ce qui a été
mesuré exactement pour le métal
ok mais quel type de morceaux
précisément combien de temps etc et de
l'autre côté la mesure de la dépression
selon quels critères une auto-évaluation
une échelle standardisés ou autre chose
un point essentiel qui est décrit dans
la section matériel méthodes c'est la
taille des groupes
ça va être important pour la suite un
est ce qu'on parle d'une analyse faite
sur 15 patients ou 15000 un petit nombre
pas forcément dire que c'est une
mauvaise étude 1 mais comme vous vous en
doutez ça va jouer sur la confiance
qu'on peut avoir dans les résultats
et d'ailleurs les résultats bat
parlons-en dans la section suivante les
auteurs présentent donc leurs résultats
attention en principe il doit s'agir des
résultats bruts 1 factuelle sans
interprétation ni commentaire ça ça
viendra plus tard les résultats se
présente généralement sous forme de
graphiques ou de tableaux et parfois ce
sont des chiffres simplement mentionné
dans le texte
les résultats présentent l'impact du
facteur variable dans notre exemple
fictif le fait d'écouter du métal sur
notre cible ici la dépression par
exemple comme un diagramme comparant les
différents groupes
le premier truc à regarder c'est la
taille de l'effet par exemple sur
l'échelle qui mesurent la dépression
quel est l'écart observé entre les deux
groupes le groupe qui a écouté du métal
et le groupe de contrôle qui n'en a pas
écoutés si l'écart est faible
ok ça veut pas dire que le résultat est
faux ou il est intéressant c'est une
information potentiel sur l'existence
d'un effet mais ça n'est peut-être pas
un truc révolutionnaire car des liens en
tête que si on arrive à démontrer de
façon convaincante qu une influence de
ce genre existent même si l'effet est
très faible
ça peut suffire pour être publiés dans
une revue scientifique mais c'est pas
pour autant qu'on va soigner la
dépression dans le monde avait du
metallica et c'est souvent là que les
articles grand public font croire monts
et merveilles au contraire font des
trucs alarmiste pour des effets
démontrés qui sont parfois faibles une
fois qu'on a la taille de l'effet qui a
été observé c'est aussi le moment de
confronter ça à la taille des groupes
dans les expériences
bah oui suivant qu'on a fait l'étude sur
15 ou quinze mille personnes
eh bien on n'aura pas le même regard sur
le résultat en effet intuitivement si on
a un groupe de 15 personnes n'a
peut-être que certaines iront mieux ou
moins bien pour des raisons x ou y un
personnel est indépendante de ce qu'on
leur fait goûter et on risque peut-être
de tirer des conclusions sur l'impact du
métal
alors que non c'est juste un effet du
hasard alors qu'avec un groupe de quinze
mille personnes et bien ce risque de
fluctuation statistique est évidemment
quand même très réduit mais attention à
pas être trop sévère 1 parfois si
l'effet est vraiment énorme et bien un
groupe de petite taille peut suffire
pour le montrer de façon assez
convaincante
donc il faut pas forcément disqualifier
les études sur des petits groupes
mais bon de façon générale plus l'effet
est gros et plus les groupes son grand
bien plus le résultat est solide et dans
le cas contraire il faut faire attention
aux risques d'anomalies statistiques
heureusement pour quantifier ça les
statisticiens ont pensé à tout
il existe une manière de mesurer
mathématiquement ce risque c'est ce
qu'on appelle dans le jargon la valeur p
ou bien le petit p ou encore la paix
value en anglais chaque fois qu'on a un
résultat qui comparé deux groupes ou une
corrélation entre deux variables
on peut lui associer une valeur qui va
être liés entre autres à la taille de
l'effet et à la taille des groupes plus
cette valeur p est faible plus le
résultat est solide statistiquement la
convention habituel en sciences c'est
qu'on ne commence à considérer un
résultat pour le publier que si le petit
p est inférieure à 0 05
au dessus on considère qu'il ya un trop
gros risque que ce soit une anomalie
statistique
évidemment ce seuil de 0,05 c'est une
convention un peu arbitraire et donc si
vous avez pour un résultat un peu cheap
et à 0,048 c'est publiables mais c'est
quand même léger est pas hyper
convaincre ça veut dire que soient les
faits est très faible soit votre groupe
est vraiment petit ou un peu des deux et
on est dans un cas où une seule étude ne
suffira pas pour conclure quand le petit
p est inférieur à 0,001 ou même 10 - 4
ou 10 mois cinq là ça devient plus
solide
d'ailleurs souvent les articles ne
mentionne pas les valeurs exactes mais
juste un seuil d'une info du genre petit
peu plus petit que 0,001 et donc quand
vous voyez petit pays est plus petit que
0,05 vous savez que ça passe tout juste
1 c'est sous le seuil de 0,05 mais pas
sous celui de 0,01
quand on a un peu cheap et qui est
suffisamment faible on est face à ce
qu'on appelle un résultat
statistiquement significatif mais
attention à la confusion car il ya un
piège de langage en français tous les
jours on emploie parfois le mot
significatifs comme synonyme de
importants ou élever les ors les
températures ont augmenté de façon
significative ça sous-entend beaucoup en
statistiques significatives signifie
probablement pas due à une fluctuation
mais ça ne dit rien a priori de la
taille de l'effet si vous avez un très
gros groupes et que vous mettez en
évidence un effet très faible et bien le
résultat peut être statistiquement
significatifs et donc publiables mais
pas forcément significatif au sens
important bien imaginons que tous les
signaux semblent au vert on a des
groupes de grande taille le protocole
est robuste les faits démontrés semble
important le petit paix est donc très
faible
est ce qu'on peut pour autant conclure
définitive
et bien non il peut encore y avoir délié
et si les auteurs font bien leur travail
ça doit être mentionné dans la partie
suivante la discussion
[Musique]
dans la partie discussions les auteurs
interprètent leurs résultats en principe
la section précédente donnait juste les
résultats factuel et il est maintenant
temps de les discuter de voir comment il
se relie à l'hypothèse initiale aux
études existantes etc
c'est aussi la discussion qui permet de
préciser les limites de l'étude et
d'envisager des pistes de recherches
futures
une délimitation qu'on retrouve souvent
dans ce genre d' analyse et qui doivent
être discutées dans la conclusion c'est
la présence de ce qu'on appelle des
facteurs de confusion
reprenons à nouveau notre exemple fictif
du heavy metal et de la dépression
imaginons qu'on n'ait pas fait une
expérience proprement dite mais qu'on
est collecté et analysé des données avec
un questionnaire sur un grand nombre de
personnes lundi dont 15 me imaginons que
dans ce questionnaire on l'aurait poser
des questions à la fois à propos de
symptômes de dépression et aussi au
sujet de leurs goûts et habitudes
musicales la quantité de musique qu'ils
écoutent le genre les circonstances
étaient terrain et supposant qu en
analysant les données on trouve que
parmi ceux qui écoute du heavy metal il
y à vraiment moins de dépression super
soignant la dépression et du métal oui
sauf qu'il ya peut-être un tenez s'il ya
plus d'hommes que de femmes chez les
fans de métal je sais pas si c'est le
cas mais imaginons vu qu'on sait que la
dépression est un peu moins fréquentes
chez les hommes que chez les femmes
eh bien ça peut suffire à expliquer la
différence globale entre les deux
groupes sans qu'ils aient le moindre
effet spécifique de la musique métal
c'est un exemple de l'adage corrélation
ne veut pas dire causalité on a une
corrélation entre le fait d'écouter du
métal et la prévalence de la dépression
mais qui s'explique par l'existence d'un
troisième facteur le sexe qui influe sur
l'un et l'autre ont dit que le sexe est
un facteur de confusion alors ici
l'exemple que je donne et volontairement
caricaturale un car si ce genre d'étude
existait les chercheurs auraient
évidemment penser d'avancé un biais de
ce genre et ils auraient pu le compenser
ce ou en formant des groupes avec la
même proportion d'hommes et de femmes
soit à l'aide d'un traitement
statistique spécifique qu'on appelle
contrôler les facteurs de confusion mais
malgré ça il peut toujours exister des
effets plus subtils et des facteurs de
confusion qui nous échappent et qu'on ne
peut donc pas traitée par exemple
peut-être que les fans de heavy metal
ont une meilleure situation
socio-économique en moyenne ou
naturellement plus de relations sociales
ou qui ne vivent pas exactement dans le
même environnement
des exemples au hasard donc même quand
il ya à priori un gros effet même quand
le petit p est faible voire très faible
donc que le résultat est statistiquement
significatifs il peut rester des billets
et pour ceux qui veulent en savoir plus
sur ce piège statistiques je vous
renvoie à ma vidéo sur le paradoxe de
simpson
il existe un moyen infaillible de se
prémunir de ces billets et ses facteurs
de confusion
c'est de faire ce qu'on appelle une
expérience randomisés l'idée serait
plutôt que d'analyser des données
existantes de faire une expérience en
attribuant une intervention au hasard
dans notre cas vous prenez un groupe de
gens vous le diviser en deux au hasard
c'est important au premier vous fait
écouter du métal et où second autre
chose et au bout d'un certain temps on
vous comparer par exemple la prévalence
de la dépression
si les groupes ont bien été tiré au
hasard alors ça élimine tous les risques
de facteurs de confusion
même ceux auxquels on n'aurait pas pensé
et on peut par ce moyen démontré une
vraie causalité un pas juste une
corrélation la difficulté c'est que
faire ce genre d'expérience c'est long
et coûteux
et oui c'est plus facile de collecter
des réponses de 15000 personnes à un
questionnaire sur les habitudes
musicales et les symptômes dépressifs
que de prendre ces mêmes 15000 personnes
de les obliger pour la moitié à écouter
régulièrement du métal et pour l'autre
moitié je sais pas moi michel sardou
puis de les réexaminer tous au bout d'un
an pour voir l'évolution des symptômes
dépressifs
ça c'est le genre de chose que
logistiquement on peut peut-être faire
avec quelques dizaines de personnes mais
pas plus et parfois c'est même
matériellement impossible ou éthiquement
douteux bah oui les forcer à écouter du
sahara doux quand même et c'est pour ça
que sauf exception les expériences
randomisés se font toujours sur des
groupes relativement petit et donc à la
fin avec un niveau statistique de preuve
parfois faibles donc quand vous lisez
une étude il est vraiment très important
de comprendre si c'est randomisés ou pas
car si ça n'est pas eh bien il ya
toujours un gros risque de facteurs de
confusion et donc pas de solution
miracle pour faire une expérience
parfaite c'est pour ça qu'une étude
unique ne suffit pas en général à
conclure un effet de ce genre le
consensus scientifique n'est toujours de
l'accumulation de plusieurs études avec
des protocoles variées par des équipes
varié il faut pas l'oublier
voilà avec toutes ces étapes vous
devriez avoir une idée plus argumentée
de la valeur et de la portée d'une étude
scientifique au delà des gros titres
qu'on peut trouver dans certains médias
évidemment ce que je vous demande de
faire là ça fait partie en principe du
travail d'un bon journaliste
scientifique travail qui d'ailleurs ne
se limite pas à ça puisqu'il implique
aussi souvent des interviews des auteurs
mais aussi surtout d'autres chercheurs
qui donnent leur avis sur l'étude
le problème c'est que les médias
accordent de moins en moins d'importance
à la science est donc au fait d'avoir
des journalistes scientifiques de
qualité et beaucoup de rédactions n'ont
simplement pas du tout à cela s'ajoute
le fait que pour des raisons de
communication les universités font
parfois de la survente des travaux de
leurs chercheurs à coups de communiqués
de presse qui embellissent largement les
résultats et donc quand vous lisez un
article qui est écrit à la va vite par
un journaliste non spécialisés qui se
contente de reprendre un communiqué de
presse eh bien ça peut parfois donner
des gros titres complètement trop peur
si ces questions d'esprit critique
vis-à-vis des publications scientifiques
vous intéresse il y à d'autres chaînes
qui en parle je vous recommande
notamment la chaîne macroscopique qui
traitent souvent de cela est parfois al
ahly et décortique des articles vous
pouvez aller notamment voir cette vidéo
elixis se demande si le soutien-gorge
donne vraiment le cancer du sein
voilà merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo
mettait un pouce bleus la cloche tout ça
et à bientôt pour toujours plus de
services
[Musique]